meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
herzlich willkommen zur pressekonferenz
in der staatskanzlei
journalisten sind schon wie in den
letzten tagen zugeschaltet abfragen von
außen sind möglich über den aktuellen
sachstand zum corona virus in bayern
informieren sie ministerpräsident dr
markus söder wirtschaftsminister hubert
aiwanger innenminister joachim herrmann
und gesundheitsministerien melanie huml
herr ministerpräsident meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren liebe
mitbürger mitbürger leider müssen wir
uns heute schon wieder an sie wenden
corona hat unser land fest im griff
heute morgen gab es eine pressekonferenz
des robert koch institutes mit nahezu
flehentlichen appellen dass wir alles
tun müssen um die fallzahlen zu senken
um unser land zu schützen
wir haben alle in den letzten tagen viel
getan in deutschland aber auch in bayern
leider ist aber noch deutlich mehr nötig
die zahl der infektionen steigt
dramatisch an
allein in bayern von gestern auf heute
eine zunahme von über 35% 817 fälle sind
gestiegen die infektionsketten sind
praktisch nicht mehr nachvollziehbar und
nach den neuesten prognosen es robert
koch institut ist aber auch unseres
landesamts für gesundheit ist wenn wir
nicht stärker eingreifen entsprechend
hohe wellen an infektionen zu erwarten
vielleicht sogar in deutschland in die
millionen bereich hinein
wir bedauern sehr dass auch die zahl der
toten steigt auch in bayern von gestern
10 ab heute zum stand jetzt 15
das ist eine steigerung um 50 prozent
wir bekommen wenn wir nicht aufpassen
eine ähnliche tendenz wie in italien
oder frankreich bereits jetzt steigt die
kurve in deutschland stein an
gestern gab es noch beratungen
verschiedene experten auch politiker in
deutschland da einander empfohlen
vielleicht noch eine woche zu warten
oder zehn tage und zu sehen
auf die bislang beschlossenen maßnahmen
reichen ich sage für bayern es
entwickelt sich nicht gut ich und wir
können nicht verantworten zu warten
wir dürfen nicht zögern jede infektion
jeder tote ist zu viel
unser oberstes gebot ist die menschen zu
schützen und ich sage deutlich
auch solche vor sich selbst die wären
nämlich erlebt haben die bundeskanzlerin
in einer bewegenden ansprache im
fernsehen noch einmal eindringlich zu
eigen verantwortung aufgerufen
auch ich habe das im landtag gemacht
kollegen in baden württemberg wir haben
ausdrücklich gesagt bitte mitmachen
jeder kann einen anderen helfen leider
sind die ergebnisse die wir gestern
gehört haben unsere polizei berichtet es
viele bürgerinnen bürger dann nicht zu
ermutigend essverhalten sich zwar
unglaublich viele menschen vorbildlich
aber es gibt auch sehr viele die das
immer noch nicht ernst nehmen immer noch
nicht den ernst der lage verstanden
haben und sich tatsächlich als gefahr
weisen für sich aber eben auch für
andere
es gibt nach wie vor corona partys es
gibt jugendliche die sich einen spaß
daraus machen ältere menschen an zu
wussten und corona zu rufen
und es gibt halt vor allem unglaublich
viele gruppenbildungen ich verstehe dass
bei schönem wetter geht man raus
manch einer sitzung der verbliebenen
gastronomin dann noch und ganz eng
bestuhlt jeder platz wird genutzt
wir können es aber nicht mehr
akzeptieren wir müssen etwas tun
wir bekommen unglaublich viele hilferufe
aus der bevölkerung mail social media
auch briefe die bitten handelt noch
entschlossener noch konsequenter unsere
kommunalpolitiker mit denen wir im
ständigen austausch stehen
beispielsweise der oberbürgermeister
landeshauptstadt münchen die da weiter
viele viele landräte bitten uns die
handlung und weiterzuentwickeln und
jetzt noch einmal eine deutliche
maßnahmen zuzulegen
sogar aus der wirtschaft kommt der
wunsch nach mehr beschränkungen und
unsere uni kliniken und ärzte sagen
genau jetzt ist der richtige zeitpunkt
zu handeln deswegen warten wir nicht auf
endlose abstimmungen in endlosen
sitzungen und gremien sondern wir
treffen die entscheidung auf
der gesetzlichen grundlage die wir in
bayern haben als staatsregierung und
handeln wir müssen versuchen es ist
unsere einzige möglichkeit der zeit wir
müssen versuchen die welle der
sprunghaften infektionen zu brechen
wir müssen jetzt war eine bestimmte zeit
fast vollständig runter fahren damit wir
später auch irgendwann wieder hochranken
wir dürfen die entwicklung nicht
verschleppen
wir können nicht halbherzig handeln
sondern wir müssen jetzt alles
einbeziehen
der maßstab ist zu uns ausschließlich
der schutz der bevölkerung dabei zählt
jeder tag
es gibt um unserem nachbarn die diese
entwicklung bereits eingeleitet haben
weil sie auch vor uns betroffen sind
es gibt beispiele wie man damit umgehen
kann ich glaube nicht dass ein deutscher
sonderweg auf dauer richtig ist ich
glaube wir sollten uns den entwicklungen
und den möglichkeiten die andere bereits
in erfahrung am nicht verschließen
bayern ist und das sage ich ausdrücklich
eine grenzregion deswegen bei ähnlich
wie in baden württemberg oder saarland
und rheinland-pfalz besondere
herausforderung es ist anders als in der
mitte deutschlands beispielsweise jeder
tut übrigens dass seine jeder tut seine
pflicht wie die unsrige um zu
entscheiden wie in bayern ich habe
gestern ein langes gespräch mit dem
bundeskanzler aus österreich geführt
sebastian kurz wir werden unser konzept
zum schutz der bevölkerung jetzt eins zu
eins an österreich orientieren und
entsprechend anpassen
viele bundesländer mit denen ich geredet
habe auch ministerpräsidenten baden
württemberg sachsen saarland planen
ähnliches oder gleiches was wir jetzt
tun wir hatten bis vor wenigen minuten
ein sitzung des bayerischen kabinetts
per telefon schalte und haben eine
einstimmige entscheidung gefällt was
jetzt ich ihnen darstellen darf über
allgemeinverfügung und auf der grundlage
des infektionsschutzgesetzes ordnen wir
folgendes an
ab freitag und das gilt jetzt ab
freitagnacht also heute nacht vorläufig
auf die dauer von zwei wochen ab 0 uhr
beginnen
wird es in bayern grundlegende ausgangs
beschränkungen geben
wir sperren bayern nicht zu er spannt
bayern nicht ein
aber wir fahren das öffentliche leben in
bayern nahezu vollständig herunter ab
morgen gilt noch viel mehr als jetzt
bleiben sie zu hause gehen sie nur in
ausnahmefällen aus machen sie bitte auch
zu hause keine partys laden sie nicht
die nachbarkinder ein und feiern
sozusagen eine art ferien partie halten
sie abstand zu anderen und wenn sie
getestet sind und auf ihr testergebnis
warten
machen sie so weit es möglich ist für
sich selbst quarantäne was ist jetzt
erlaubt was ist verboten erlaubt es
natürlich jeder soll und kann zur arbeit
geben aber die bitte auch in die
arbeitgeber nachdrückliche bitte dafür
zu sorgen dass mindestabstände
eingehalten und home office ermöglicht
wird wo es nur geht
jeder kann auch weiterhin medizinisch
versorgt werden und zum arzt gehen
aber es gibt für einige bereiche
einschränkungen physiotherapeuten
beispielsweise nur in notdienst in
notfällen andere dinge wie logopäden und
ergotherapeuten werden geschlossen
hatten wir schränken die betretungsrecht
und die besuchsrechte in speziellen
einrichtungen für risikogruppen
grundlegend 1
das heißt für alten- pflegeheimen
behinderteneinrichtungen ist das
besuchsrecht generell verboten nur im
sterbefall in palliativ fall ist es
erlaubt für krankenhäuser geht nahezu
das gleiche keine besucher mehr
kein besuchsrecht mehr nur in drei
fällen im sterbefall wenn eltern ihre
kinder die im krankenhaus sind auf
kinderstationen besuchen wollen müssen
und bei einem freudigen ereignis
natürlich wenn geburt ansteht und väter
beispielsweise mutter und kind besuchen
wollen und beiwohnen wollen das
öffentliche leben wird heruntergefahren
aber die lebensmittelversorgung des
alltäglichen lebens bleibt wie bislang
erhalten
es gibt keinen anlass für hamsterkäufe
ich hatte mich die woche nochmals selbst
überzeugt davon es gibt auch viele
gespräche auch der wirtschaftsminister
den landwirtschaftsministern waren dabei
es gibt keine engpässe mit der
lebensmittelversorgung sind braucht es
keine hamsterkäufe und auch künftig die
banken geöffnet sind keine sorge man
braucht keine bargeldabhebungen jetzt zu
tätigen oder zu machen was im vergleich
bislang aber noch eingeschränkt wird ist
friseurin werden nicht mehr geöffnet
baumärkte und gartenmärkte werden
geschlossen weil es sich in vielfältiger
form zu einer art freizeit idee
entwickelt hat dorthin zu gehen
wir werden auch die gastronomie ab
morgen grundlegend schließen keine
gastronomie hat mehr geöffnet nur noch
wenn es um turbo drive inn oder
entsprechende lieferungen geht
dies ist auch etwas was nahezu alle
bundesländer jetzt umsetzen wollen nun
zu der frage wie geht man im freien
bleiben sie zu hause ist das motto außer
sie müssen arbeiten oder sie wollen sich
medizinisch versorgen
wir sagen aber auch wir wollen bayer
nicht zu sparen wir wollen auch kein
lagerkoller erreichen
frische luft tut gut und kann auch
helfen in dieser situation aber das ist
jetzt wichtig natürlich ist spart
möglich oder spazieren gehen
das wird übrigens auch in österreich
beispielsweise erlaubt aber entweder
allein oder mit der familie oder mit dem
hund wenn man rausgehen muss um
entsprechend tierbedarf zu machen aber
keine gruppenbildung keine partys keine
großen menschenansammlungen sind künftig
mehr erlaubt es ist ganz wichtig dies zu
sehen natürlich kann man zu seinen
kindern und kann auch seine geschiedene
mann geschieden ist seine kinder
besuchen
aber ansonsten allein oder die familie
das ist in dieser zeit wichtig dies sind
die maßnahmen die jetzt getroffen wenn
wir bieten wirklich sehr und verständnis
und auch um mithilfe das ganze zu machen
weitergehende maßnahmen sind denkbar das
sind ab regelungen die sind zulässig
wenn es bestimmte gemeinden gibt in
denen ein solcher hotspot entsteht wie
wir sie in mitterteich der fall hatten
dort ist es den kommunen und gelassenen
abstimmung mit uns
tatsächlich so etwas weiter zu machen
überwacht und kontrolliert wird das
ganze von unserer polizei in
ordnungsdiensten es gibt keine passagier
scheine wie beispielsweise in frankreich
aber die polizei wird das massiv
kontrollieren wie haben sie gestern
bereits sensibilisiert bei
entsprechenden menschen sammlung
wer dagegen verstößt wer nicht
einsichtig ist der muss mit hohen
bußgeldern rechnen
wir müssen dies jetzt konsequent für
alle durchsetzen
zum schutz der oder die freiwillig
mitmachen aber auch zum schutz derer die
am noch uneinsichtig sind wir können da
keine ausnahmen machen
ich weiß das sind starke einschränkungen
vorläufig für 14 tage
es gibt auch keine garantie dass alles
sofort wirkt alles zeitversetzt aber es
ist die einzige möglichkeit nach
empfehlung aller experten jetzt noch
diese welle zu verflachen abzubrechen
vielleicht sogar ist grundlegend zu
ändern
für die vernünftigen unter ihnen und
alle die dies hören und sehen für die
vernünftigen ändert sich wie sie gemerkt
haben gar nicht mal so viel aber für die
unvernünftigen gibt es jetzt ein klares
regelwerk
bitte helfen sie auch mit zu
identifizieren und in allen anderen
vielleicht dann auf zuruf anzusprechen
dass er sich danach halten soll auch
noch ein persönliches wort
das alles fällt nicht leicht solche
entscheidungen zu treffen
man ringt mit sich wir ringen mit uns
ist es richtig beine ist ein
freiheitsliebenden landwehr heißt noch
freistaat bayern
die menschen sind gern frei und wollen
auch diese freiheit leben
jeder nie gedacht dass ich als
ministerpräsident solche entscheidungen
treffen muss es hilft jetzt nichts die
kann man nicht wegducken
wir wollen uns nicht wegducken wir
wollen jetzt mit ihnen zusammen diese
krise durchstehen
das sind maßnahmen die man es vor langer
zeit nicht hätten träumen lassen ja vor
wenigen tagen vielleicht sogar nicht
aber sie sind notwendig wir treffen
diese entscheidungen nach besten wissen
und gewissen
nach rücksprache auf der grundlage der
empfehlungen von medizinern biologen den
zuständigen behörden und bei uns im
kabinett
es geht um den schutz von uns allen und
wir müssen jetzt auch handeln
es ist ein charaktertest vorbei es gibt
vorbildliches großartiges engagement spd
fortsetzen
und diejenigen die sich schwer tun
diesen charakter test zu bestehen
den geben wir jetzt riegeln mitzumachen
und sich einzubringen es einfach bitter
ernst zu nehmen
warum tun wir das jetzt ich konsequent
ihr jetzt herangehen je schneller wir
die maßnahmen treffen
je entschlossener alle mitmachen unser
ehe besteht die chance dass wir keine
situationen gekommen wie wir sie in
china und anderswo erlebt haben eine
sehr verdammen und herren wir
beschäftigen uns jetzt mit der situation
der medizin
wir werden noch größere auswahl bei der
wirtschaft bekommen das wird an anderer
stelle diskutiert auch da stehen wir
unsere wirtschaft seit an seit
ihr kommentar auch durch es gibt auch
bayern nach corona aber es gibt umso
stärkeres bayern acht euro wenn wir
jetzt uns nicht wegducken sondern wenn
wir handeln wenn wir es zusammen machen
ich danke für ihr verständnis ich bitte
um ihre mitarbeit jede einzelne kurz
unsere heimat und bleiben sie gesund
wirtschaftsministerin ein wahrer liebe
bürgerinnen und bürger vielen dank dafür
dass sie alle mithelfen das
wirtschaftssystem in bayern aufrecht zu
erhalten und damit weiterhin die
versorgung der bevölkerung zu sichern
wir haben ja es staatsregierung
innerhalb weniger tage ein sehr
erfolgreiches soforthilfeprogramm corona
auf den weg gebracht wo wir mittlerweile
über 50.000 anträge haben von bürgern
vom ein mann und ein frau betrieb bis
hinauf zum 250 mitarbeiter
mittelständler die er aktuell nicht mehr
liquide sei also keine größeren
bargeldmengen aktien gold und
dergleichen mehr zur verfügung hat und
jetzt flüssig werden muss flüssig
bleiben muss dafür ist dieses
hilfsprogramm gedacht zwischen 5.000
euro und 30.000 euro
dass man nicht zurückzahlen muss bisher
war immer bei einigen neuen
missverständnis die meinten dass sein
also zurückzahlen muss nur der wo wir im
nachhinein feststellen dass er uns nicht
die wahrheit gesagt hat und durchaus
noch nennenswerte beträge auf dem konto
hatte und damit geld in anspruch
genommen hat das für andere menschen
gedacht ist oder in die jetzige menge an
anträgen bedeutet schon mehrere hundert
millionen euro bayerische steuerzahler
geld vom nachbarn vom arbeitskollegen
und sonst wem es ist also nicht vom
himmel gefallen sondern wir verteilen
hier nur um deshalb biete hier auch
sorgsam mit der moral umgehen und die
dinge nur beantragen wenn sie es nötig
haben
dann hält auch das system durch an der
stelle großer dank an die
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter der
bezirksregierungen und der
landeshauptstadt münchen die jetzt auch
übers wochenende hindurch diese anträge
bearbeiten die ersten zahlungen bei den
betroffenen sind heute freitag schon auf
dem konto angekommen die größte welle
dürfte ab dienstag mittwoch auf ihren
konten landen und wir werden dann weiter
beobachten wie sich die zahl entwickelt
für diese sofort gilt das ist aber bei
weitem nicht die einzige maßnahme die
der freistaat bayern ergreift um seine
wirtschaft zu stützen
wir bitten sie wenn sie finanzbedarf
haben gehen sie zu ihren hausbanken wir
bieten unseren haus von sparkassen
genossenschaftsbanken und privatbanken
vor ort lukrative bedingungen des
freistaats bayern der rückversicherung
der risikoübernahme damit die ihnen
zeitnah für ihre kredite geben können
damit ihr betrieb weiterläuft sie können
ja personal auch jetzt frei stellen hier
dank an den bund um ebendiese
kurzarbeiter regelung in anspruch zu
nehmen wo sie dann aber nur 60 bis 70
prozent des nettolohns zu noch zur
verfügung haben und hier kämpfe ich
derzeit dafür und ich hoffe dass wir uns
gemeinsam mit dem ministerpräsidenten
durchsetzen können in berlin dass
künftig es möglich ist dass menschen die
kurzarbeitergeld beziehen
weil ihr automobilzulieferer als
beispiel schließt das diese menschen
andere arbeiten aufnehmen können und
dort dazuverdienen dürfen wo wir die
dringend brauchen im lebensmittelbereich
in den supermärkten stecher in der
landwirtschaft wo wir dringend personal
brauchen es wäre unsinnig wenn wir die
leute zu hause sitzen hätten die arbeits
willig sind und das können und nicht
dürften weil der bund oder regelungen
hier im wege stehen
das soll ab montag geklärt werden ich
hoffe ich auf gute ergebnisse
dann hoffen wir auch auf großzügigkeit
des bundes in puncto stundung von
steuern und sozialabgaben damit wir hier
die leute flüssig halten und nicht ihnen
erste bilder vom konto abbuchen um dann
wieder mit soforthilfe gilt kommen zu
müssen also auch hier ist der bund
gefordert uns zu unterstützen er tut das
auch und kündigt auch große finanz
beträge an über die kfw damit wir
kredite an die wirtschaft und die
betriebe herausgeben können wir sind
derzeit auch daran die kritische
infrastruktur auf ihre
belastungsfähigkeit zu überprüfen das
heißt die elektrizitätswerke die
wasserversorger die haben wir genau im
blick dass dort nicht aufgrund von
corona fällen plötzlich die
elektrizitätswerke nicht mehr arbeiten
könnten
so machen sie sich da keine sorgen diese
kritische infrastruktur funktioniert und
wird das weiter tun
ich danke auch den lebensmittelbetrieben
die hier jetzt die
nahrungsmittelversorgung aufrecht
erhalten um so nötiger wenn sie nicht
mehr im restaurant und gasthaus zum
essen gehen können müssen sie
lebensmittel kaufen können das ist
gewährleistet und bleibt gewährleistet
wir haben hier die möglichkeit der
flexiblen öffnungszeiten aber die werden
derzeit noch kaum benötigt gehen sie mit
vernunft zum einkaufen wieder
hamsterkäufe noch wegen einem glas guten
dort reinlaufen reduzieren sie ihre
infektionsgefahren kaufen sie sinnvolle
haushaltsübliche mengen und den sich
schnell wieder raus und gehen sie nicht
mit der ganzen familie zum einkaufen
sondern einer bleibt zu hause und passte
auf die kinder auf
keiner kauft ein nicht die ganze familie
um dort einfach dieses besuchs aufkommen
in den supermärkten zu reduzieren
ich danke und er stelle auch ganz
besonders unseren landwirtinnen und
landwirten die in den letzten monaten ja
viele angriffe und viele probleme
aushalten mussten wir sind froh dass wir
sie haben vielleicht mehr als uns früher
bewusst war sind wir froh dass wir einen
starken bauernstand in bayern haben der
die lebensmittelversorgung mit fleisch
mit milch mit eiern mit gemüse
sicherstellt also danke für eure arbeit
und vielleicht trägt es auch dazu bei
dass man sie nach dieser krise wieder
mit anderen augen sieht es geht auch
darum das thema des unmittelbaren
gesundheitsschutzes der medizinisch
tätigen der pflegeberufe sicherzustellen
deshalb hat der freistaat bayern jetzt
als erstes bundesland ein eigenes
produktionsprogramm für masken aufgelegt
heißt also wir haben konkret bayerische
firmen aufgesucht ich bin persönlich
draußen gewesen bei einem
automobilzulieferer beispielsweise der
sitzbezüge nähert für die autos jetzt
keine aufträge mehr rat wer ist jetzt
mit unserer unterstützung zu material
gekommen und masken zu produzieren
schutzmasken atemschutzmasken und wird
das in diesen tagen auf hohe stückzahlen
hochfahren
genau so eine andere firma die hier mit
schneider waren solche dinge erledigt
also wir werden dann mehrere zehntausend
stück bayerische masken pro tag
produzieren können übers wochenende
geht's schon los weil sich
herausgestellt hatte dass internationale
lieferketten nicht mehr funktionieren
das zugesagte lieferungen aus welchen
teilen der welt auch immer in bayern
nicht ankommen angeblich angelieferte
ware gar nicht existiert und dergleichen
mehr
deshalb nehmen wir auch jetzt eine
eigene lagerhaltung hier in angriff und
werden an der messe münchen eine halle
mit unseren ausrüstungsgegenständen dann
bestücken um von dort aus zentral wieder
raus zu liefern also bayern macht ihr
jetzt eigene masken wir gehen auch in
dieses thema desinfektionsmittel
wir arbeiten gerade auch das läuft auch
in diesen tagen hoch desinfektion von
einkaufswägen desinfektion von
medizinischen gerät und dergleichen wenn
das mit desinfektionsmittel nicht mehr
gehen sollte wenn es engpässe werde mit
mit heißem wasser 140 grad heiß die
dinge erhitzen sterilisieren und
dergleichen mehr und man kann darüber
lachen aber wir denken darüber nach die
produktion läuft an für bettwäsche für
note hotelbetrieb wenn wir hotels wo ich
denn als ausweich kranken wo es eher
denken wir sogar und die bettwäsche für
mögliche kranke die wir dort einlagern
also das nehmen wir selber in die hand
weil einfach die märkte weil die
zulieferung nicht mehr funktioniert und
damit glaube ich ihnen gesagt zu haben
wir sind an allen fronten unterwegs wir
sind auch erfolgreich die
massenproduktion ist da die sofort
kredite laufen die wirtschaft wird
unterstützt bitte halten sie durch wir
kriegen das hin die paar wochen kriegen
wir uns genau ausstiegsdatum wissen wir
heute nicht aber es wird nicht ein
halbes jahr dauern es wird nicht ewig
dauern
es wird einige wochen dauern dann müssen
wir aus dieser nummer wieder raus da bin
ich überzeugt also halten sie durch wie
kriegen das in andere länder haben ist
teilweise schon hinbekommen das leben
geht weiter aber damit es weitergeht
müssen wir jetzt gemeinsam vernünftige
und stark sein wir tun unser bestes tun
auch sieht aus vielen dank heute durch
bevor mir zu ihren fragen kommen noch
zwei kurze statements vom zunächst
innenminister joachim herrmann
meine damen und herren um die bayerische
polizei hat in den letzten tagen bereits
konsequent kontrolliert und überwacht
dass die in den letzten tagen schon
erlassenen besonderen vorschriften und
beschränkungen auch beachtet werden
wir konnten feststellen dass das in den
allermeisten fällen tatsächlich der fall
ist es konnte nur leider auch einige
verstöße festgestellt werden es wurde
entsprechend ermahnte es wurden in
wenigen einzelfällen auch entsprechende
bußgeldverfahren eingeleitet mir ist
wichtig dass die bürgerinnen und bürger
die allermeisten tun dass nun wirklich
selbst einsehen wie wichtig diese
vorschriften zu ihrem eigenen schutz und
zum schutz anderer mitmenschen sind
entsprechend wird die polizei dann ab
dem morgigen tag
diese besonderen ausgangs beschränkungen
auch kein besonders kontrollieren
jeder jede ist aufgefordert die lebenden
falls glaubhaft zu machen warum jemand
unterwegs ist das gilt für den weg zur
arbeit genauso wie für die besonderen
bedingungen unter denen man auch weiter
sonst unterwegs sein darf
aber es ist wichtig dass das ernst
genommen wird und deshalb werden wir den
polizeistreifen diesen bereich noch
einmal weiter verstärken
natürlich ja auch wissen dass
kontrollieren dass betriebe
beispielsweise im einzelhandel der nicht
lebensmittel oder gesundheitsversorgung
dient auch tatsächlich geschlossen sind
und wir werden die normalen polizei
kräfte hier auch noch durch zusätzliche
kräfte der bereitschaftspolizei
verstärken damit die bevölkerung über
all diese polizeipräsenz wahrnehmen kann
ich glaube das können die bürgerinnen
bürger auch zu recht erwarten ich
bedanke mich herzlich für das engagement
das hier von der polizei geleistet wird
und ich schliesse in diesen dank
ausschließlich ein ausdrücklich auch
unsere feuerwehren und
rettungsorganisationen mit einem die
hauptamtlichen und auch die
ehrenamtliche kräfte die auch wie ich
das gerade wieder vorgestern in
mitterteich erleben konnte natürlich
konsequent ihren einsatz auch leisten
bis hinauf zu den kolleginnen und
kollegen der sicherheitswacht wir wollen
alles dafür tun dass auch in dieser
situation selbstverständlich sicherheit
und ordnung in bayern in dem hohen maß
wie das die menschen
erfreulicherweise ja gewohnt sind
gewährleistet bleiben
gesundheitsministerin melanie huml
liebe bürgerinnen und bürger in bayern
mir ist es noch mal wichtig ihnen zu
erklären warum diese maßnahmen unbedingt
erforderlich sind
wir haben einen anstieg der fälle auf
über 3.000 infizierte in bayern
das heißt aber auch dass wir nicht
wollen dass diese kette weiter hoch
steigt sondern dass wir die möglichst
unterbrechen können und diese krankheit
wird übertragen eben das ist eine
tröpfcheninfektion
das heißt eben da wo menschen nah
beieinander sind kommt es möglicherweise
zu dieser tröpfcheninfektion deswegen
überall wo es möglich es möglichst
eineinhalb zwei meter abstand zwischen
den menschen haben und
menschenansammlungen geht es gesamt
nicht mehr
deswegen sind diese maßnahmen so
dringend notwendig selbstverständlich in
den familien dass man da weiter
beieinander ist dass man zusammen
spazieren gehen kann als familie wo man
ja im engeren austausch ist aber sich
eben nicht andere menschen dazu holen wo
wir nicht wissen können ob vielleicht
schon jemand dabei ist er infiziert ist
und dann die eigene familie mit ansteckt
möglicherweise dann ist innerhalb der
familie wieder an die großeltern
weitergegeben wird die besonders
gefährdet sind
die maßnahmen sind deswegen so wichtig
und es mag sein dass der ein oder andere
jetzt denkt oh was muss kommt alles auf
mich zu sie können weiter zur arbeit
gehen sie können weiter zum einkaufen
gehen sie können weiter zum arzt gehen
aber alles was eben nicht dringend
notwendig ist das wird eingeschränkt für
14 tage vorerst
und ich glaube das ist eine maßnahme die
jeder mitmachen kann und die auch jeder
mitmachen muss wenn ich das so deutlich
sagen darf wir werden auch noch mal dort
einschränkungen vornehmen wo eben die
besonders gefährdeten gruppen sind dass
es bei den älteren menschen und bei den
schon erkrankten das heißt eben auch
dass wir besucher in alten und
pflegeheimen untersagen werden
das trifft nicht so wenn jemand im
sterben liegt das soll ein verabschieden
innerhalb der familie möglich sein
es ist auch so dass während jemand zur
geburt seines kindes dabei sein möchte
der papa oder
das soll möglich sein im krankenhaus
aber auch sonst im krankenhaus
besuchsrechte noch mal runterfahren
verbieten weil es einfach notwendig ist
es hier infektionen nicht rein getragen
werden
das ist alles nicht einfach das sind bin
ich ja das sind wir uns als bayerischer
staatsregierung wirklich bewusst aber
wir müssen diese schritte gehen wir
sehen innerhalb europas wenn wir zu spät
entscheiden was dann entstehen kann
wir können nicht versprechen ob diese
maßnahmen helfen alles dadurch zu
unterbinden
aber wir müssen diese schritte gehen um
unser möglichstes in unserem
verantwortungsbereich zu tun
helfen sie mit weil wir müssen noch
weiter uns darum kümmern dass
schutzmasken kommen ich bin sehr dankbar
dass der wirtschaftsminister hier auf
bayrische produktion setzt weil wir
bisher das was wir bestellt und zum teil
schon bezahlt haben es sehr schwierig
war dass es angekommen ist auch der bund
wird uns aber in den hoffe ich nächsten
tagen hier nochmal was liefern können
weil wir das dringend für die praxen für
die krankenhäuser benötigen aber hier
setzen wir auch auf bayrische produktion
um ein stück weit unabhängig zu sein
wir tun alles was in unserer macht steht
aber wir müssen alle mithelfen
deswegen bleiben sie gesund bleiben sie
möglichst zuhause
damit wir diese situation durchstehen
können vielen dank ich möchte ich darauf
hinweisen wegen der besonderen umstände
müssen wir uns heute auf fünf fragen
beschränken der pressekonferenz sie
können sich vorstellen es gibt noch viel
zu tun heute
ich kann ihnen aber auch versichern alle
fragen werden im anschluss von den
pressestellen beantwortet es wird keine
unter den tisch fallen und auch nochmal
informationen für alle die
allgemeinverfügung wird online
nachzuverfolgen seien im unmittelbaren
anschluss an die pressekonferenz wird
auf sämtlichen kanälen der
staatsregierung gesendet wenn sie auf
die webseiten der ministerien schauen
wenn es ist auch nachvollziehen und da
werde dann vielleicht auch einige oder
die eine oder andere detail frage die
sich jetzt schon stellt auch beantwortet
werden wir beginnen mit der ersten frage
von christine schröpf mittelbayerische
zeitung was bedeutet die ausgangs
beschränkung für die wirtschaft und den
handel
und ob die 800.000 angekündigten
schutzmasken aus
der bund schon eingetroffen sind in
bayern sondern als erstes die masken des
bundes sind nach auskunft des
bundesgesundheitsministers unterwegs
sowohl an die kassenärztliche
vereinigung für die praxen als auch an
die entsprechenden an unseren des
gesundheitsministerium
da sind gehen wir davon aus dass das
alles kommt das zweite ist was ergänzend
ist man muss auch von der summe her
ergänzen ist also viel kann gerne
produziert und ist das was er jetzt in
bayern gemacht hat man ausdrücklich
danke schön auch für die bemühungen ist
hier in bayern zu schaffen sehr sehr gut
nur der grad schon beschrieben und wir
erleben dass in den nächsten tagen
natürlich auch die märkte sich wieder
neu justieren
in china wird wieder steigen produziert
sodass wir davon ausgehen dass wir in
diesen bereichen auf dauer keine
herausforderungen haben können sind wir
können das schaffen was mir mehr sorgen
macht ist ehrlicherweise die
wirtschaftliche entwicklung hubert
aiwanger das schon angesprochen
wir brauchen dringend einen raschen und
schnelle nationalen kraftakt wir haben
beschrieben was jetzt alles offen ist
oder wir merken auch wie sich die
wirtschaft im moment stück für stück
runter fährt
es wird die größte herausforderung für
uns werden diese rezession die droht zu
bestehen
vor allem wird wichtig sein dass am ende
wie nicht ein übernahmekandidat werden
deutschland in bayern darf kein
übernahmekandidat
deswegen ist erforderlich dass wir jetzt
schnell helfen und zwar mit großen
summen die maßnahmen des freistaats
bayern greifen bereits wurden bereits
angesprochen mit geld wenn es so
unbürokratisch wie möglich machen wir
sind auch bereit ständig nachjustieren
und auch im zweifelsfall mittel zu
erhöhen und sie einzusetzen auch was
kredite betrifft da gibt es kein limit
da gibt es keine beschränkung wir
versuchen es so gut und stark wie
möglich zu machen aber ist auch wichtig
das ist auf nationaler ebene gehandelt
wird noch schneller als tempo voran
gebracht wird wir werden auch zu
unkonventionellen maßnahmen greifen
müssen beispielsweise auch mögliche
übernahmen von miet verpflichtungen von
darlehensverträgen die jetzt schon
laufen um die kosten so zu reduzieren
und liquidität der betriebe zu halten
und es muss im zweifelsfall auch
überlegt werden wir waren es für bayern
tun
der bund muss das auch tun sollten
übernahmeangebot aus dem ausland statt
hervorragende betriebe zu kaufen
technologie zu kaufen dann müssen wir
alle möglichkeiten des rechtes an wenn
dies zum teil zu untersagen und es
vorübergehend dann sogar mit staatlicher
beteiligung zu erhalten
denn wenn am ende dieser krise steht
dass nahezu die gesamte bayerische und
deutsche wirtschaft in ausländischer
hand ist wir keine steuerungsoptionen
haben dann ist es nicht nur eine
medizinische krise
dann ist das auch eine komplette
änderung der weltwirtschaftlichen
ordnung auch dagegen müssen wir uns was
ja natürlich bringen die jetzigen
einschränkungen viele verwerfungen an
die wir gestern noch nicht gedacht haben
mein erstes interesse gilt jetzt die
kräftige ziel dort einzusetzen wo sie
hingehören also der vom
automobilzulieferer frei werden die
mitarbeiter dann dorthin wo
nahrungsmittel produziert werden oder an
andere im postbetrieb um nicht hier
strukturen kaputt zu machen die wir
dringend brauchen auch eine
größtmögliche unabhängigkeit von
ausländischen arbeitskräften zu bekommen
wir sehen zunehmend das osteuropäische
länder ihre grenzen dicht machen und es
immer schwieriger wird an die es
dringend nötige personal hier anzukommen
da werden wir jetzt vieles selber
stemmen müssen vielleicht auch in
berufen wo wir bisher gemeint haben das
ist nicht mehr unser niveau
es darf hier kein berufsbild mehr geben
wo man sagt das ist mir nicht würdig
jeder muss überall hin pfosten wo er
gebraucht wird
wir müssen auch von unten her die
strukturen sichern im handwerk im
kleinen mittelstand in der gastronomie
wir sehen ja gerade im bereich des
tourismus ein großes wegbrechen jetzt
von aufträgen die ganzen hotels sind
dich die gastronomie ist ich das sind
hunderttausende menschen die dort
gearbeitet und davon gelebt haben
die müssen jetzt vielleicht bei einem
lebensmittel versorger mithelfen die
lebensmittelversorgung aufrecht zu
erhalten im supermarkt und dergleichen
mehr
damit einfach das gesamte system
funktioniert und die große industrie
darf nicht jetzt zusammenbrechen dorf
nicht außer landes gehen darf vor allem
nicht aufgekauft werden
auch hier bin ich dafür dass wir sehr
sehr genau hinschauen dass hier nicht
strategische kooperationen laufen und
wir im windschatten des aufräumens der
krise am ende feststellen dass uns viel
ist nicht mehr gewährt was wir morgen
brauchen sie es wird jetzt nichts
verkauft was wir morgen noch brauchen da
wird genauer hinschaut wie in der
vergangenheit auch im bereich des
gesundheitsamts thema krankenhäuser auch
die krankenhäuser werden jetzt teilweise
probleme bekommen finanzielle ort heißt
also hier wird der staat hier wird die
öffentliche hand wieder mehrere hingehen
müssen um diese strukturen zu sichern wo
in der vergangenheit vielleicht durch
zuviel liberalisierung auch fehler
gemacht worden sind also jetzt geht es
darum das system funktionieren zu halten
wir kriegen das hin wir müssen aber mit
denken und dürfen keine denkfehler
machen nächste frage
roland englisch nürnberger nachrichten
wurden liegt noch der unterschied zu
einer ausgangssperre
wie hoch werden die bußgelder ausfallen
und ob sie herr ministerpräsident am
sonntag für eine bundesweite
ausgangssperre plädieren zudem
ordnungsgelder würde ich dann
innenminister bieten was zu sagen und
zwei dinge eine eine totale
ausgangssperre würde ja bedeuten dass
man nicht mehr aus dem haus das der
unterschiede ausgangssperre wieder
bedeutend keiner darf mehr verlassen
das ist zum beispiel in china so gemacht
worden dort ist eine komplette
ausgangssperre gemacht worden
das tun wir jetzt nicht deswegen jetzt
auch ausgang beschränkung denn wir
wollen auch tatsächlich nicht ein land
einsparen jetzigen zeitpunkt wollen auf
keinen fall auch wirklich lagerkoller
erreichen die leute müssen ja die
möglichkeit haben mal an die frische
luft zu gehen sie müssen auch zur arbeit
gehen können
sonst bricht alles zusammen und sie
müssen eben auch zum arzt gehen wir
haben die dinge ja alle gerade eben
geschrieben was die anderen bundesländer
machen muss jeder selber überlegen
ich habe vorhin schon erwähnt dass viele
überlegen gerade die gastronomiebetriebe
zu schließen
es wird jetzt im heutigen laufe des
tages möglicherweise überlegt da gibt es
eine insgesamt tendenz bei vielen
bundesländern das zu tun was noch nicht
entschieden war für ihn aber viele
werden es auf den weg bringen nach den
telefonaten nicht geführt habe ich will
keinem etwas vorschreiben um gottes
willen das ist nicht meine aufgabe aber
ich habe bereits in der letzten runde
darauf hingewiesen ich werde es wieder
tun wir sind auch stärker betroffen als
bayern
ich will niemand etwas vorschreiben wie
er macht seine aufgabe in rolle aber wir
sind stärker betroffen gespülte zahlen
und wir treffen die entscheidung
aufgrund der gesetzlichen grundlagen die
für bayern gelten
und ich glaube es wäre gut wenn viele
folgen die bußgelder
nachdem infektionsschutzgesetzes des
bundes können verstöße gegen eine solche
verordnung wie sie mit dieser
allgemeinverfügung lassen je nach
tatbestand mit bis zu 25.000 euro
bußgeld belegt werden
die nächste frage kommt von wolfgang
ranft bild zeitung gibt es eine
gruppengröße die jetzt in der
öffentlichkeit untersagt ist und wird
die polizei personalien kontrollieren um
festzustellen ob verwandte gemeinsam
unterwegs sind oder bekannte besuchen
oder ob jemand unerlaubt unterwegs sein
wird die polizei wird stichprobenartig
natürlich personen kontrollieren die
sich im öffentlichen raum aufhalten
da wird es personen geben die dann eben
glaubhaft machen dass sie auf dem weg
zur arbeit sind oder von der arbeit nach
hause da ist jemand offenkundige auf dem
weg zum einkaufen oder nach hause
man darf eigentlich auch mit seinem
lebenspartner mit dem man in häuslicher
gemeinschaft lebt auch zusammen
durch den wald joggen bitte immer den
nötigen abstand einhalten weil es wird
natürlich auch kontrolliert werden ob
jemand ohne dass all diese gründe
vorliegen die sie den vollen ja auch
geschildert worden sind unterwegs ist
und dann kann das gegeben weil es von
der polizei auch beanstandet werden es
gilt was jeder mit dieser verfügung und
festgelegt ist und das ist nicht nur zum
zeitvertreib für juristen gedacht
sondern es ist der maßstab an dem wir
wirklich alle jetzt unser öffentliches
leben unser verhalten in der
öffentlichkeit in den nächsten zwei
wochen zunächst einmal orientieren und
das ist auch sehr sehr ernst gemeint und
entsprechend erwarten wir auch und
können auch die ganz große mehrheit der
menschen in diesem land die das
zweifellos davon wenig überzeugt für
richtig hält was wir hier festgelegt
haben
das erwarten die auch dass auch alle
anderen sicht darum halten und dafür ist
die polizei zuständig die nächste frage
kommt von lisa schnell süddeutsche
zeitung sich das richtet sich an den
ministerpräsidenten
sie sagten es dürfe kein
kompetenz-wirrwarr unter den ländern
geben ob diese unterschiedlichen regeln
aus ihrer sicht problematisch sein und
dann eine spezial frage her nicht in den
minister wahrscheinlich ob die
überwachung der maßnahmen auch der
einsatz von drohnen geplant ich sehe im
moment keinen anlass nur die wachen
durch drohnen weil es ja wie sie aus dem
text der schon ergibt dann geht ob
jemand im einzelfall eine glaubhafte
begründung habt weshalb öffentlichen
raum unterwegs ist und diese glaube auf
die begründung kann nur im persönlichen
gespräch der polizeibeamten mit den
bürgerinnen und bürgern festgestellt wir
wollen kein kompetenz wirrwarr und
zuerst der aufgabe reizt eine
einheitliche regelung zu finden zwischen
uns und kommunen haben wir haben gestern
sehr viele telefonate geführt und er
heute mit landrat mit roma bürgermeister
die und sehr gebeten haben eine
landeseinheitliche regelung zu treffen
dem sind wir nachgekommen wir sind auch
der festen überzeugung dass es gut ist
wenn wir bundesweit diese standards
haben faktisch aber es ist anders in
einigen bundesländern situation als bei
uns wir spüren dass in baden württemberg
oder im saarland ganz ähnliche
herausforderungen sind über uns denn
dort sind die jeweiligen grenzen zu
frankreich sondersituationen bei uns ist
besonders österreich oder der schweiz
wir können an der stelle nicht endlos
warten wir müssen eine entscheidung
treffen
wir haben uns das wohl überlegt wir
haben beraten sehr intensiv und es hat
sich jetzt über nacht auch noch einmal
verstärkt weil wir gestern leider erlebt
haben dass die appelle sowohl von grund-
als auch von den jeweiligen
ministerpräsidenten auch von mir
wir haben das ja gestern noch einmal der
regierungserklärung gemacht nicht so
gefragt sind
und das ist viele gibt die den ernst der
lage zone 10 mit sehen können es
vielleicht auch nicht ernst nehmen ist
auch kein vorwurf unbedingt manch einer
macht sich ein negativen spaß draus und
deswegen ist es jetzt einfach notwendig
das zu tun
wir stehen vor einem wochenende feiern
ist das wäre jetzt schön viele wollen
dann auch rausgehen
es ist jetzt wichtig an diesem
wochenende allein an diesem wochenende
infektionen neuinfektionen zumindest zu
reduzieren und die kurve abflachen zu
wollen
deswegen ist das handeln zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt schlicht und einfach natürlich
zum wochenende passt die abschlussfrage
von klaus rimpel tz davon mit dem auto
in den wald fahren und dort zu joggen
oder mit dem hund gassi zu gehen mit in
den wald fahren in der regel nur bis zu
dem parkplatz am rand bis weil es die
meisten fälle sind nicht wer das
durchfahren von autos geöffnet aber dann
gilt ausdrücklich sport und bewegung an
der frischen luft ist entsprechend
erlaubte und deshalb kann man genauso
zum beispiel auch joggen und kann dabei
auch von angehörigen des eigenen
hausstandes begleitet werden
es soll aber bitte nicht dienen dazu
dienen dass dann wieder neue
gruppierungen gebildet werden
also es ist nicht gedacht daran dass
hier dann wieder fünf oder zehn oder
fünfzehn menschen bitte gemeinsame sport
gruppen bilden die ihr im wald unterwegs
sind
aber die einzelne sportliche betätigung
das joggen durch den wald oder ähnliches
ist selbstverständlich erlaubt genauso
das spazierengehen dann schließen wir
die pressekonferenz ich danke für die
aufmerksamkeit und möchte noch mal
verweisen darauf die allgemeinverfügung
wird im internet auf den seiten der
staatsregierung nachzulesen sein
danke vielen dank